(papers rattle)
Okay, Joy?
Joy: Here.
Joy..
Trea?
Trea: Here.
Aiko?
Aiko: Yes.
Grace?
Teacher: No Grace?
Teresa?
Hello.
Jenny?
Jenny: Here.
Hey, I'm Anna.
I'm Brad.
What kind of white are you?
What?
Is it Irish?
You look really Iry.
I--Iry?
Yeah. It's short for Irish.
Alright.
Let's do some, uh,
warm-up improv scenes.
No suggestions.
You're under arrest for embezzling
from Bank of America!
Throwing ME under the bus, Officer Kelly?
But you were the mastermind behind the whole thing!
Oh, you're gonna rat me out?
Classic wimpy, white man.
Where's your honor?!
(laughter)
(gasp)
I'm not hiding any Jews.
Nein!
A sword collection?
Really?
Your yellow fever's getting out of control, man.
Crash this beer can on your forehead, frat boy!
For Delta U!
You know, I'm not really a religious person, but...
this pope is pretty chill.
Yeah. (scoffs)
I mean, I even started going to church.
Are you two--
OH MY GOD, IT'S THE PEDOPHILE PRIEST!
Get out of here!
(Brad screams)
Get out!
Brad: Okay, hold--I'm sorry, I'm sorry,
do you not have a note on this?
Yeah.
Super funny, Brad.
(laughs)
But you could--
You could...commit more.
It seems like you're hesitating.
The initiations are pretty stereotypical.
Really? I--
I didn't notice that.
Frat bro?
Embezzler?
Pedophile priest?
I mean, I know these are the only portrayals of
white men in media, but...
that doesn't mean that we're ALL like that.
Nobody's saying that, Brad.
It's just a little frustrating, you know?
To...not see someone who looks like me
in..class or on the stage, I mean,
even at the higher levels, it's all just Asian women.
Hey, "funny" is "funny", dude.
It's not our fault that most people in improv
are Asian women.
"Funny" is also subjective,
I mean, you guys have a very particular sense of humor.
And you're gonna identify with other Asian women--
Wait, are you saying..
we're racist?
Hey, my boyfriend's white!
Nonononono,
NOT racist.
Maybe...
unconsciously biased?
Alright,
I think we all...
we all heard Brad,
thank you, for speaking up,
but let's--let's keep the politics out of here
for a little bit, and--and get back to work.
Um,
Brad, why don't you initiate a scene.
Whoa,
that new whey protein's really
doing a number on your traps.
Yeah.
Wrap it up, broski.
We're late for a Coldplay concert.
And there are a bunch of
women we need to shame into
fucking us~
(laughter)
Really?
(laughter continues)
(subsides)
(footsteps)
(door closes)
I'd still do him.
Yeah.
Ah...
dick.
People have this weird urge
to comment on my race.
So, what exactly ARE you?
Um, well I'm Japanese, Hawaiian, Filipino--
Whoa,
you are way too Asian.
...English, German, Spanish, French, Irish..
Wow.
You are not Asian enough.
It's especially weird when they say,
"You're white-washed."
Subtitles by Skylar Coland via Amara